BY DEFENSEMEN.
WHAT YEAR R
BRANDON MONTOUR ON THE SECOND
BARKOV WILL PICKFEED BARKOVOVTA
YOUR TICKET  WHEN
THE REASON THIS GOAL HAPPENED
WAS THERE WAS TRAFFIC OUT IN AR
TEND TO GO ON THE PENALTY. Stev
CARTER KEEPS THE
PANTHERS WEWESTEERED
AWAY.
GUDAS GOT IT YOU WANT.
HAD
SEVEN POWER PLAY'S TO THE
OPPONENT.
HERE AN OPENING NIGHT THE
PENGUINS HAVE SEVEN AND WE ARE
BOYLE.
MARINO GOT THE STICK ON IT.
HUBERDEAU SESAVE ON THE FIRST
ATTEMPT BY JAKE AGAIN SOUL. JUS
TRICKLES OVER THE GOAL LINE.
NOT SURE  WITH ZUCKER.
BEBEJUST GAVE,
THAT LOOKS LIKE A GOAL.
.
BENNETT'S LINE ON THE ICE.
AARON EKBLAD UP TO 23 MINUTES
ALREADY.
BENNETT BACK FOR TH THE FIVE-MA
ATTACK AND THAT IS EXACTLY HOW
THE GUENTZEL AND SAYING THE
PANTHERS WON'T GET A POINT OUT
OF THIS LEFT IN THE TANK TO FIN
OFF YOUR IN OVERTIME?
THEY HAVE LOGGED SOME E PENGUIN
HAVE A BREAKAWAY.
RODRIGUES IS IN ON